[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avenue au monde c'est fait comme tout le
monde une grossesse normale et quand
maman a senti la grossesse elle est
partie voir mon papa naturellement et
elle lui a dit
et le gars il a regardé ma maman et
comme tout bon père il a reconnu la
grossesse
mais il a ajouté que vu l'avancée de son
âge il pouvait pas s'occuper de la
grossesse en fait parce que si
l'investit le temps que moi je réussisse
j'irai déjà bon en fait je pouvais pas
lui rendre l'appareil non non il y a des
gens qui se sentent choqués ou non ne
vous sentez pas choqué en fait parce que
le gars il est dans le futur il a
compris jusqu'à présent j'ai pas encore
réussi mais le gars il est mort en 2008
imaginez aussi il avait investi sur moi
c'était à peine en fait
sérieusement et moi je suis vraiment
habitué à ça parce que quelqu'un n'est
avec ce genre de chèque je me suis dit
ma vie c'est que des échecs en fait donc
je commence à me préparer aux échecs et
vous devez comprendre que
automatiquement ma maman a joué le rôle
de mon père et de ma mère ma parole
logiquement ta maman je le rôle de ton
père et de ta mère tu dois être un bon
enfant n'est-ce pas parce que pour créer
une personnalité il faut savoir que déjà
pour la personnalité moi ma définition
de la personnalité c'est que c'est
l'ensemble des connaissances qu'on
acquiert durant tout notre moment sur la
terre en fait et ses connaissances en
les reçoit ou dans notre famille avec
l'éducation que nous parlons nous
donnent et moi ma maman m'a dit une
chose elle est pas loin dans les études
mais elle va s'arranger pour ne pas
qu'on dise que si on n'a pas réussi
c'est de sa faute en fait
comme ça et de parler de votre musique
et donc pour un moment a commencé à
payer mes cours j'ai commencé à aller à
l'école mais honnêtement j'imaginais pas
d'être humoriste un jour
mon premier rêve c'était d'être pilote
ouais
et moi actuellement quand je pense à ça
je me pose des questions frais tu
comptais sur quoi pour faire ça en fait
sérieusement parce que plus on évoluait
je me rendais compte que j'aimais pas à
l'école en fait et je m'éloignais plus
des maths et des physiques chimiques qui
pouvaient me permettre de consolider une
bonne base pour essayer d'espérer être
un jour pilote moi j'aimais m'amuser
donc c'est mort il y a plus une histoire
d'être pilote en fait il y a pas ça
échec
et je suis à bobolais et vous avez
toujours des clichés sur notre commune
non c'est la violence c'est vrai mais
aussi le football et j'ai voulu être
footballeur à un moment de ma vie
comme on le dit chez nous l'homme
propose et Dieu dispose mais moi dans
mon cas l'homme a proposé ma maman était
là pour bloquer que Dieu dispose en fait
non heureusement elle m'a dit clairement
tu veux partir à l'école d'accord tu
veux jouer au football d'accord mais il
faut savoir que pour jouer au football
on doit avoir un diplôme en fait que
Drogba Didier un diplôme il a le bac
après moi je savais qu'il y avait des
footballeurs qui sont vraiment là qui
n'ont pas joué au football que je
connaissais mais tu payes pas des loyers
tu payes pas de facture d'eau tu n'as
pas de mot à dire deuxième rêve était ça
fait combien trois échecs pour commencer
et je commence à rentrer dans la
délinquance parce que j'ai mes amis on
joue au jeu de hasard je commence à
jouer je prends l'argent de la facture
pour aller jouer au jeu je gagne pas et
je me rappelle qu'une fois je jouais et
j'ai gagné et la personne que j'ai gagné
l'a dit elle n'allait pas me laisser en
fait
quand on dit je vais pas te laisser
c'est qu'ils vont envoyer un groupe
derrière toi pour faire des histoires et
maman avait peur elle m'a envoyé à
Bouaké
donc je suis arrivé à Bouaké je me suis
dit bon comme tu m'envoyais à Bouaké ils
sont gris toi tu n'as pas d'argent et
toi tu penses que tu attends mot à dire
en fait tu vois donc je disais quand
même à part demander mon avis pour
m'envoyer à Bouaké
je vais écouter les coups en fait donc
je partais à l'école mais je faisais pas
les cours j'avais pas une bonne moyenne
j'ai repris ma classe de seconde et
après j'ai commencé à prendre conscience
me dit mais c'est tu peux pas être
footballeur parce que si tu essaies de
jouer au football à Bouaké le temps
d'arriver à Abidjan tu seras vieux
ouais c'est pour ça qu'il y a d'autres
qui diminuent leur âge en fait tu vois
tu seras vieux donc c'est pas possible
en fait je peux pas être pilote bon
après je suis pas assez pas intelligent
j'arrive à comprendre ce que les
professionnels disent j'arrive à bien
mais à bien réagir quand je veux à
l'école et du coup j'ai commencé à dire
ok je vais à l'école juste pour faire
plaisir à la fin en fait pour montrer
que je suis intelligent avoir les
diplômes mais je sais pas quoi faire en
fait et je vais je vais je vais en créer
une tour de théâtre dans l'école je dis
bon ok c'est pas grave jamais distrait
parce que je suis seul à Bouaké je vais
me distrait donc je commence à faire les
scènes les gens commencent à apprécier
et il y a un professeur qui m'a dit ben
en fait toi ce que tu fais c'est mieux
d'aller à l'INSA que tu vas
perfectionner ton truc et puis ça peut
te donner à manger en fait après le bac
j'ai dit à ma maman je vais étudier le
théâtre honnêtement je connaissais pas
les débouchés du théâtre
mais en vrai je sentais que je
travaillais pas quand je faisais du
théâtre et je suis quelqu'un qui est
beaucoup paresseux
ouais
et donc j'ai décidé de pas dire faire le
théâtre mais la femme elle comprenait
pas mais dis non tu peux pas partir
étudier pour faire rire parce que
elle-même nous faisait rire tout le
temps à la maison en fait donc moi je
lui ai dit en fait si je fais le théâtre
je savais pas j'avais pas d'assurance je
dis je fais le test je vais passer dans
les films en fait et elle a accepté elle
a payé les cours j'ai passé le concours
ça a marché je suis arrivé là-bas je
croyais que j'allais être aussi facile
que ça en fait que je suis arrivé dans
l'école bon je fais la rotation en fait
j'ai tourné sur mon comme on disait os
CE1 la terre tourne sur elle-même
pendant 24 heures pendant le jour et la
nuit c'est-à-dire quand la tête tourne
un résultat en fait mais moi pendant
deux ans j'ai tourné mais il y avait pas
de résultats et je me rendais compte que
j'étais nul
j'étais pas fait pour le métier parce
que je faisais des castings en me
prenait jamais il y a une seule fois ils
m'ont pris et j'ai appelé ma maman pour
lui dire ah cette fois-ci là je tourne
un film mais ça va passer tel jour et il
faut regarder et quand le film est passé
j'ai eu mon passage a fait 10 secondes
acheter figurant tu vois et j'ai même
pas parler en fait ça fait 10 secondes
et donc vous comprenez que quelqu'un
peut pas payer des cours et puis tu vas
venir faire 10 secondes en fait tu vois
donc j'avais plus le courage de lui
demander de l'argent et je pouvais pas
aussi être distribué dans les scènes
parce qu'on me disait que pour une pièce
de théâtre il faut avoir une formation
il faut avoir un jeu d'acteur bon
quelqu'un qui est en première année jeu
d'acteur il gagne ça ou en fait donc je
pouvais pas tu vois et donc du coup j'ai
participé à beaucoup d'ateliers de
formation pour pouvoir développer mon
niveau tout et j'ai rencontré des
personnes j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
personnes et aussi à côté je me disais
que cette je vais à l'école mais j'ai
pas d'argent en fait tu dois manger
parce que si tu n'as tu as faim pour
étudier c'est compliqué donc j'ai
commencé à faire des livraisons de
chaussures en fait c'était mon ami qui
était étudiant et qui faisait des
livraisons et à chaque fois il me
donnait 500000 francs il s'appelle
Anthony Kramo Aaron et je lui ai dit un
jour au lieu de me donner tout le temps
1000 francs 500 est-ce que tu vas pas me
m'aider à faire les livraisons en fait
il m'a dit il y a pas de souci alors à
jamais donc souvent quand vous êtes sur
Internet et puis vous voyez des choses
si vous pensez que ça quitte aux
États-Unis c'est nous qui les livrons en
fait on est à jamais
et je continue des dents et pendant mes
ateliers de formation parce que j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de personnes et il y
avait un spectacle de restitution d'un
atelier de formation et j'ai croisé
quelqu'un il s'appelait Wilma Yao
c'était un humoriste et après le
spectacle moi j'écoutais beaucoup la
radio en fait parce que j'aimais
beaucoup la radio et je voulais faire la
radio mais
la direction de la radio c'est pas celle
que j'ai prise en fait donc c'est mort
tu vois et donc je lui ai demandé mais
comment on fait pour intégrer votre coin
il m'a dit non viens c'est tous les
dimanches en 15 si tu as un test tu
viens tu dis tu veux jouer puis ils vont
te programmer bon moi je quittais à Bobo
quand commando va arriver à l'école de
gendarmerie à Cocody parce que l'endroit
c'était le Bao café donc je venais tout
le temps maintenant sur le dico je
venais tout le temps et je disais moi je
veux jouer bon après c'est là que j'ai
compris que relation est mieux que
diplôme on te connaît pas tu joues pas
si tu veux faire drôle comment commander
tout le temps je venais je venais je
venais et un jour avant d'arriver à un
jour parce qu'il faut expliquer bien
comment ça s'est passé en fait en fait
il y a les serveuse dans la salle il y a
une que je vais pas oublier son nom
jusqu'à ce que je meurs elle s'appelait
l'or
en fait la dame elle était au marquage
c'est-à-dire que vous venez et vous
demande vous prenez quoi bon moi j'ai la
boisson c'était 1000 fois en fait une
bouteille de sucrerie c'était 1000
francs mais mon transport aller-retour
Abobo c'est 1000 francs
imaginez si je paye je fais comment pour
retenir sachant que c'est dimanche le
lendemain il y a les cours en ligne
donc j'étais obligé de lutter souvent
que tu viens je me cache non je dois
jouer à chaque fois et un jour on dit
bon lui il vient tout le temps il veut
jouer programmant le c'est bon tout le
temps tu viens toujours pas en te donne
l'opportunité montre-nous ce que tu peux
et je fais quoi je fais un test sur la
masturbation
bon après l'humour tout le monde faisait
l'humour pour faire rire beaucoup pense
que l'humour c'est pour faire rire juste
pour faire rire donc moi je fais un test
sur la marche je commence à jouer mon
test et là où Madame la Ministre assise
il y avait un enfant qui était là en
fait
et à côté il y avait sa maman
et moi je me suis à fond dans mon test
en fait je joue je joue et pendant que
je joue je vois la maman qui ferme les
oreilles elle bouge les oreilles de son
enfant en fait
et moi c'est ma première chaîne moi je
comprends pas donc ça me casse en fait
échec tu vois après je suis habitué
maintenant sinon à l'époque c'était
vraiment ouais et je finis je descends
mais je sens que je n'ai pas bien joué
je sens que ma prestation n'a pas marché
maintenant ça il y a des amis qui
viennent de ah non c'était bien non tu
as tué c'est là j'ai compris c'est là
j'ai compris qu'il y avait l'hypocrisie
dans le métier des arts et j'ai commencé
à ah ouais d'accord aimer parmi tu vas
tous ces personnes là il y a quelqu'un
qui s'est démarqué lui il m'a pas dit
directement en fait il m'a envoyé un
message sur WhatsApp Mehdi en fait ton
passage n'a pas marché pas parce que ton
test n'était pas drôle
mais juste parce que tu n'assumais pas
ce que tu disais
il me lui raconte quoi
en humour il faut faire rire mais il
faut avoir de la personnalité en fait ce
qui fait que même si quelqu'un te vois
pas ils sont automatiquement qu'on pense
à toi il sait que c'est toi donc du coup
moi je me dis ah d'accord donc je dois
faire quoi ah ouais il y a des clichés
sur Abobo mon vécu d'accord je commence
à écrire mes tests je lui demande est-ce
que tu peux m'aider à structurer mes
tests parce que je connais pas il dit il
y a pas de souci premier test je crée un
test de 4 pages je dis c'est pas un
documentaire on est là pour faire rire
on se retrouve à une page donc je dis ok
d'accord on commence à écrire un jour on
joue mais je suis pas programmé en fait
parce que je suis déjà passé ça n'a pas
marché donc faut pas je vais venir
gratter le public en fait donc je viens
tout le temps je viens tout le temps et
un jour je suis arrivé et ceux qui
étaient programmés les stades de la
soirée n'était pas vite arrivé en fait
donc on me dit que l'intéresse va tu as
3 minutes
donc je joue j'écris pas les tests en
fait je joue mon vécu pour dire non une
fois je suis arrivé ici j'ai rejointage
sur ça ça n'a pas marché les gens
commencent à rire et je sens que les
gens sont à fond en fait je dis bon on
m'a donné 3 minutes il faudrait pas que
je dépasse sinon vous n'allez plus me
voir sur cette chaîne mais si c'était
tout pour moi tout le monde applaudit et
c'est non non ça fait pas non
tu vois et on commence à me programmer à
me programmer mais c'est pas tout le
monde qui comprend en fait il y a des
gens qui disent nous on comprend pas
c'est pas drôle et que j'arrive à mettre
mes prestations sur la sur Internet les
gens qui met en vente des critiques mais
comme s'ils me connaissait en fait non
c'est pas drôle ce que tu fais ça fait
pas rire tout et tout et moi je suis à
fond dans mon truc en fait parce que je
me dis je suis un peu dans je suis
habitué à perdre en fait monsieur doit
pas être il faudrait pas que j'accuse
les autres vous pouvez me dire c'est pas
trop le je vais arrêter et quand ça va
marcher dit que c'est sa faute en fait
je veux que si ça marche pas c'est moi
ma faute c'est moi qui ai décidé de
prendre ce chemin là faut que j'assume
donc j'étais des dents j'écrivais un
truc et Montreux comédie vient en Côte
d'Ivoire il faut un casting bon après
moi je me suis dit je fais ça c'est
peut-être dans 10 ans que je vais
voyager c'est juste une ligne dans mon
CV et puis en avance casting on est plus
de 100 points 15 personnes je suis pas
mis les 15 parmi lesquels on doit
attirer 8 pour faire la finale je suis
pas mis les 8 et à la finale je me dis
comme à un moment vous voulez pas que je
fasse le métier des arts je vais
l'inviter elle va venir voir le
spectacle et on finit le spectacle c'est
moi qui suis retenu et je dois partir
représenter la Côte d'Ivoire à Montreux
en Suisse
donc je me rappelle que quand j'appelais
maman elle était encore dans le taxi
pour lui donner l'information elle a
fait plus d'une minute à crier en fait
ou au félicitations mon fils
félicitations mon fils et
je finis de gagner le concours on est en
masse 2019 je dois partir à Montreux en
décembre 2019 vous voyez
l'intervalle mon patron qui me
permettait de faire les livraisons à vu
que je dois partir en Suisse
je sais pas si vous comprenez
j'ai plus droit au livraison en fait je
peux plus faire des livraisons parce que
je dis je sais pas mais il y a beaucoup
qui se disent ça en fait le fait de
juste partir en Europe tu as réussi dans
ta vie en fait même j'ai dit non toi tu
peux pas partir venir faire les
livraison donc du coup ça devient
compliqué et le bas au café ou en avait
le temps de jouer deux trois fois et
puis nous donner 10000 francs pour
manger ferme parce qu'ils arrivent plus
à payer les loyers
donc il fait aimant je peux plus jouer
parce que la concurrence ne veut pas me
prendre c'est la concurrence trouve que
c'est pas elle qui m'a révélé et elle en
conflit avec Montreux qui m'a révélé
donc moi je suis là je joue plus je joue
vraiment frustré tu as méchant habitué à
l'échec ça va en attendant que je
réussisse je vais continuer à travailler
mon test écrit écrit et j'ai pas à
Montreux je reviens pareil je suis pas
sur la scène de montrer comédie tu te
dis bon là c'est fini les gens vont
comprendre maintenant ce que tu voulais
faire passer comme message mon passage
sort sur la chaîne Youtube de montrer je
dis ok ça va passer mais je vois les
commentaires après mais c'est qui lui là
il est parti faire il est parti salut
notre commune pour aller faire rire les
blancs c'est même pas drôle en fait et
c'était en 2019 moi je suis vraiment
quelqu'un je t'ai pas faux je t'ai pas
prêt mentalement le mental que j'ai
actuellement je l'avais pas en 2019 en
fait tu vois donc je dis je peux pas je
commence à me poser des questions est-ce
que c'est le métier que j'ai décidé de
faire et tu vois Adrien planez qui
m'aidait à écrire mes qui dit ah bah
d'accord faut qu'on l'aide en fait il me
dit non laisse tomber les commentaires
qu'on te donne de façon négative tu peux
les utiliser pour pouvoir et je vais
dire les utiliser entre ta faveur en
fait et donc c'est ce que je fais quand
je monte sur scène vu que les gars
disent que je suis pas drôle avant de
commencer dit bon moi je ne fais pas
rire
donc si ça vous fait rire tant mieux si
on veut pas rire vous-même vous savez
que je ne fais pas rire
après quand je dis ça tu peux plus
m'attaquer en fait je sais que
oui et pendant que je volais je voulais
à chaque fois dans mes prestations j'ai
toujours des personnes qui me disent ça
en fait et avant de partir à Montreux il
y a les amis de Adrien qui sont des des
réalisateurs qui ont décidé de monter un
documentaire pour suivre le projet en
fait pour filmer un jeune humoriste
africain comment il écrit certains pour
aller faire rire les gens de l'autre
côté qui connaissent pas sa culture et
donc moi je me dis d'accord ils sont là
ils me suivent tout et tout tu vois on y
va le truc est fini je me dis que en
Côte d'Ivoire on connaît qu'on finit de
faire deux jours après on publie bon le
titre inventé en 2019 ils me disent
qu'il cherche des clients jusqu'en 2022
c'est compliqué en fait moi je me dis le
documentaire va sortir et puis il va
monter aux yeux du monde que
effectivement quand je parlais d'Abobo
de cette manière c'était un objectif
caché derrière en fait mais le
documentaire soit pas et donc moi je
continue de travailler je continue
d'écrire mes tests avec les frustrations
que je suis même à l'école il y a mon
professeur en fait c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai considéré comme mon père
qui me dit directement toi tu n'es pas
drôle tu n'es pas fait pour être
humoriste
depuis ma base ça m'a choqué en fait
mais j'ai dit mais ça peut me motiver
parce que une de mes amis aussi qui m'a
dit toi tu penses que tu fais trop là tu
fais rire avec ce que tu racontes il y a
pas de souci donc c'est ces deux phrases
là qui m'ont vraiment motivé à écrire
mais je continue à écrire des tests et
je continue à me faire connaître en fait
dans les spectacles mais je choisissais
en fait toi tu n'as pas assez d'argent
mais c'est toi qui dit tu joues pas
d'anniversaire tu joues pas dans mariage
je suis pas dans baptême tu n'as rien
c'est toi qui a beaucoup de principes en
fait donc je jouais dans les premières
parties des spectacles mais je
choisissez les spectacles et je me
rappelle que dans une des premières
parties du spectacle de juste Crépin je
sais pas si beaucoup il le connaissent
Mariam Coulibaly était dans la salle
avec son mari et je finis de faire mon
passage
elle apprécie elle filme et aimait sur
sa page Facebook donc moi je finis je
rentre à Bouaké je vais voir ma maman et
je reçois un appel veux-tu faire de la
radio pourtant c'était un rêve que
j'avais dès le départ en fait je dis
mais il y a pas de souci en fait donc on
m'appelle sur Fréquence de et je suis
chronique sur Fréquence de dans la
matinale et ça fait deux ans maintenant
je suis chroniqué sur Fréquence 2
et les potes commence à s'ouvrir mon
humour qui n'était pas accepté par tout
le monde commence à jouer à gagner du
public et Algérie qui commence à me
soutenir il y a des gens qui me
soutiennent dès le début dans tous mes
spectacles qui sont tout le temps là
honoré Diarrassouba et sa femme ils sont
tout le temps là ils me soutiennent
bon je continue dans mon truc en fait
passer mon objectif c'est pas la Côte
d'Ivoire en fait j'ai pas envie d'être
populaire j'ai envie d'être célèbre et
votre célèbre c'est très compliqué
ouais
j'ai pas envie en fait et un moment j'ai
eu j'ai commencé à avoir de la peine
parce que ma maman m'a envoyé des
messages quand je faisais des skins je
suis à Bobo ou je parlais sur les parce
que je parlais beaucoup du gouvernement
j'attaque beaucoup le gouvernement dans
mes sketch maman m'a appelé un jour pour
me dire arrête de parler d'Abobo pardon
parce que nous avons de la famille en
fait les autres sont pas allés loin mais
moi j'étais à fond dans mon truc je
continue et je continue et
montrer revient Abidjan et rachète le
Bao et ça devient le dit coco il décide
de signer 10 jeunes humoristes qui font
du stand up et moi je suis dans la
troupe logiquement c'est ma passion je
devais être dans de bonnes conditions
pour pouvoir créer mais dès que je signe
le contrat
j'ai l'impression que ma passion est
devenue un poison en fait parce que
j'avais beaucoup de sollicitations il y
avait la radio le matin il y avait des
scènes que tu devais faire il y avait
des placements de produits que tu veux
faire donc j'arrive plus à avoir du
temps pour moi-même pour pouvoir écrire
de nouveaux tests en fait donc du coup
je commence à penser à la parole de ma
maman qui me disait que c'est pas mieux
tu vas faire communication ou bien
espagnol pour pouvoir avoir un métier où
vont te payer à la fin du mois en fait
c'est là que j'ai compris que la
sécurité à la limite c'est ce que les
parents pensent que de mieux pour nous
mais en vrai la sécurité t'enferme en
fait parce que moi je me suis dit prends
les risques
la vie sans risque ne vaut pas d'être
vécu en fait et moi j'ai pris les
risques j'ai essayé ce que je pouvais
j'ai fait et actuellement je représente
la Côte d'Ivoire un peu partout j'ai eu
aller en France je vais aller à
présenter la Côte d'Ivoire dans la
souris région au Burkina au Togo au
Niger en Guinée c'est vraiment ce que je
fais comme métier mais le message que
j'ai envie de laisser avant de partir
c'est que c'est vrai que souvent quand
tu viens d'un quartier comme Abobo ou
bien d'une famille où ça va pas on te
dit de ne pas rêver mais moi j'ai envie
de dire aujourd'hui que faudrait pas que
le manque de moyens
nous empêche de rêver mais si c'était
tout pour moi